SAAD ALI: Hello, folks.
My name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software engineer
here at Google.
And I'm joined here by Mace.
Mace is an SRE on the GKE team.
JENNIFER MACE: That's right.
SAAD ALI: Macy, can you
explain what an SRE is?
JENNIFER MACE: So SRE stands
for a Site Reliability Engineer.
And the main difference between
me and any other software
engineer is that I have more
of a focus on reliability,
scalability, and just
general efficiency
of the running of the thing
that I'm owning, which is GKE.
SAAD ALI: So what does that
mean, when you own GKE?
Are you responsible
for running it?
What do you do for customers?
JENNIFER MACE: Sure.
So the idea is that we set
SLOs, which are Service Level
Objectives, which are
measurements of how reliable we
want the running service to be.
And my job is to do any
kind of engineering,
really, that's
required to make sure
that we're meeting those goals.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
So how does this differ
from a traditional kind
of DevOps role?
JENNIFER MACE: So I
think that there's
a lot of interplay
between DevOps and SRE.
They're fairly tightly coupled.
SAAD ALI: OK.
And in terms of some of
the challenges that you
see in your day to day
job, what are they?
Can you talk about that?
JENNIFER MACE: Sure.
So I think that one of the
big challenges for GKE,
which is a massive
hosted Kubernetes system,
is really just the
diversity of use cases.
We run a five-digit
number of clusters.
And every user has
slightly different needs
and slightly different
configurations,
so we're constantly seeing
new challenges crop up.
SAAD ALI: That's awesome.
So how do you actually
deal with them?
Are there best practices?
Do you have any
suggestions for customers?
Or do you take care of
most of the pain for them?
JENNIFER MACE: So we try to
take care of anything that's
on the platform level
and anything that
is really internal, so that
anything that a user can't take
action to fix is super
frustrating for them,
and we don't want them to
have to deal with that.
But, in general,
the philosophy of
SRE to reduce the time to
mitigate a broken system.
So we may not have a perfect
fix or perfectly understand
the problem, but
our goal is always
to make the user able to
use their system again fast,
and then figure it out after
the fact with postmortems.
SAAD ALI: What
happened, and make sure
that it doesn't happen again.
JENNIFER MACE: Exactly.
And wherever possible, to build
systems to do that, and build
it into the code, rather than
relying on humans to come in
and fix something.
SAAD ALI: Very cool.
And so, when we were
talking off-camera,
you were mentioning some really
interesting design patterns
that SRE deals with.
Can you talk about that?
JENNIFER MACE: Sure.
So one of the challenges in
hosting a massive deployment
of Kubernetes clusters,
which I talked a little bit
about earlier, is that
the traditional SRE
model for a
hyperscalable system is
to build a multi-tenant system.
And what that means is that
all of your query flow and user
action is flowing
through a single binary,
or a single replicated
set of binaries.
Now, a more traditional
monolith for a single user
is what we call a
single tenant system.
So for example, an
Oracle database.
It has one user,
and it's completely
specified for that user, and
it's been tweaked and perfected
for exactly their use
case, but it's really
only useful to one
person at once.
The challenge in hosting
these Kubernetes clusters
is that every single Kubernetes
cluster is, in its own way,
from my point of view,
a single tenant system.
You know, this system
belongs to one user.
This system belongs to
a different customer.
They don't have any
interaction with each other.
And as an operator,
I can't really
treat them as a monolith.
So we're trying to develop some
new operations patterns for how
we deal with that, and keep
them all running, when they're
so different from one another.
And that's what we've been
calling, starting to call,
multi single tenant systems.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
Is this a pattern that
customers could potentially
apply in their own systems?
JENNIFER MACE: Absolutely.
Whenever you have a customer
who is building something that
has many separate users, a
pipeline, or a shop deployment,
or anything along
those lines, there
are very similar
patterns to keep in mind.
SAAD ALI: And it
definitely helps
with scalability
of their solutions.
JENNIFER MACE: For sure.
I think one of
the key principles
that we're starting to come up
with is really that automation
is king, and that monitoring
and trying to make sure
that you can have
some equivalent
monitoring between each of
your single tenant systems,
because it doesn't
matter whether you
are using your Kubernetes
cluster to host
a machine learning
pipeline and I'm
using mine to host a
YouTube front page.
Both of us have a control
plane that has uptime.
And it's meaningful to
measure control plane uptime,
and I can compare our
two clusters with that.
SAAD ALI: That's
super interesting.
Let's take a step back
and talk a little bit
about your background
and how you got into SRE.
JENNIFER MACE: So I
joined Google in 2012
as a new graduate with
a maths and CS degree.
And I went straight into
the Google Ads SRE team.
Kind of learned
everything I know.
SAAD ALI: Did you know that
you wanted to be in SRE.
JENNIFER MACE: Not at all.
I had offers from three
separate teams, and one of them
was an SRE.
And I went to some of my
friends at Google, and I said,
what's an SRE?
And they said, well, they
wear leather jackets,
and they swear a
lot, and they're
always really on the
go, and stressed out.
And I'm like, that sounds great.
Sign me up.
SAAD ALI: Oh, man.
And it seems like
you've enjoyed it since.
JENNIFER MACE: Yeah.
I'm having great fun.
SAAD ALI: What do you recommend
for new grads who are trying
to follow a similar journey?
What should they
look into, and what
are the kind of
things that can help
them determine whether
to follow the SRE
path or a different path?
JENNIFER MACE: Well,
one of the things
that they might want to have
a look at is the SRE book.
We recently came out
with the SRE workbook,
and I actually have
a write-up of one
of the big GKE outages
in that workbook,
if people are curious.
And another thing is just
try spinning up some systems,
and try breaking them.
Don't just try to
make them work.
Try to break them, and
figure out how they break.
And if that's
interesting to you,
then this might be
an area to pursue.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, I
think there might
be a lot of folks out there
that are interested in that.
So thank you for that.
Let's switch gears a little
bit and talk about KubeCon.
This is your first KubeCon.
JENNIFER MACE: Yeah.
SAAD ALI: What are
your impressions?
JENNIFER MACE: It's huge.
SAAD ALI: Yes, it is.
JENNIFER MACE: It's
really, really big.
I was a little surprised about
the gender diversity here.
My SRE team is about half women,
which is a little bit unusual,
but I was not expecting it to
be quite as masculine as it--
SAAD ALI: Male-dominated.
JENNIFER MACE: --as it is here.
Yeah.
SAAD ALI: What can we
do to improve that?
JENNIFER MACE: I mean,
I think that it's really
a question of looking at
how the community treats
various people.
I know that in the past,
I've had some challenges
with a very feminine
name in open source,
getting code reviews.
It feels like you got
a bit more pushback.
But also just one of the
things that I did notice
that KubeCon is
working on is having
technical women on stage.
Right?
All of the keynotes
have had a huge number
of really impressive
women, like Janet and Liz.
And that's something
I super appreciate.
SAAD ALI: That is awesome.
And finally, let's wrap up with,
what are you looking forward
to most at KubeCon?
Is there a talk or whatever?
JENNIFER MACE: Honestly,
I am looking forward
to talking to other people who
are using Kubernetes in ways
that we are not.
Right?
I feel like that's what
I get the most out of,
is one to one
conversations, figuring out
where people's pain
points are, how
they're different from mine.
Because I have a bit of a weird
perspective on Kubernetes.
I don't use Kubernetes.
I run Kubernetes.
Right?
So it's a bit of a--
SAAD ALI: And if
we can figure out
how customers are using it
in ways that we don't expect,
we can make it more robust
and reliable over time.
JENNIFER MACE: That's the idea.
SAAD ALI: That is
the role of SRE.
Thank you very much, Mace.
JENNIFER MACE: Thank you.
SAAD ALI: It was a pleasure
talking to you likewise.